foreign
I think that what's a value to people
who are thinking about doing ideas and
or some entrepreneurship is
to some extent recognizing your own
personalities of whether you're
actually Built For War or not and to me
all of this is a war I know my wife has
said I it's sort of sad that you see
your life is a war every day
and so I'm I'm ready and if I've got one
regret
and I've got a few of them but one of
them is I wish I was born
3 000 years ago because back then like
in a movie like Braveheart if you
believed in something so strongly you
would go to the battlefield you would
face your enemy who basically was trying
to deny you whatever it was that would
give you personal happiness or what you
thought would be good for your family
and only two things were going to happen
you were either gonna cut his head off
or he was going to cut yours
that simple and I've always been the guy
willing to go I'll die I'll die for what
I believe now unfortunately Tim
killing your enemy and cutting her head
off is illegal right and it's really
frustrating to me because man there's a
lot of heads I'd like to see on the
ground but I and I'm sure they'd like to
see mine but we can't do that we have to
be a law-abiding citizens so now what we
have to do in modern times is
sue people and take away market shares
and tell them you'll never work in this
town and it's just not nearly as
satisfying as if I could just cut their
heads off
so if I get ready for the war which
means that every day and here's I'm
going to give you a piece of advice that
don't tell your mom if you're listening
to me because moms will be horrified by
this here here it is lower the bar
lower
the bar don't raise the bar Lower here's
why
way easier to get over low bars than it
is high bars try it put a bar six feet
high try to jump over it put a bar six
inches off the ground you can get over
it 20 times in a minute it's easy lower
the bar ladies and gentlemen so that
means that I get up every day and I
don't have high expectations of anything
not even with Humanity so here's I'm not
a religious person but I do have sort of
a personal prayer and it's sort of this
simple every day today will not
be perfect
and you know many days in a row Tim I've
nailed that
every single day of my life I have no
I'm on like even a longer streak than
Cal Ripken Jr with that what tortures
people and some of you are listening are
the people who have the bar higher than
that
did you see this email this guy sent me
that son of a [ __ ] oh you thought today
was gonna be perfect did you see that
guy that guy cut me off on the freeway
right oh that guy cut me off here
in line I was waiting in line and they
cut me off getting a ticket for them for
the Black Panther movie and now I can't
get in or whatever oh oh somebody said
something about my haircut somebody said
something about that like what so you
thought that the world was going to be
perfect and that everybody was going to
wake up and that they were going to make
your life better you know who woke up in
the planet today with eight billion
people and said I'm gonna make Todd's
life better today there was only one
human being one and that was me no other
human being not even my wife that was
their mission today that was me so if
you're expecting others to make you
happy and and make it accommodating for
you you're gonna get crushed so here's
what I would say lower the bar go to
your job interview and before you walk
in give it your damndest but assume
you're not getting the job
give it your damndest but assume you're
not getting it so when they don't phone
you back and when you don't get the job
you're okay with it because if anything
you actually take it as a pride that you
actually called the shot
I knew it I knew it I went there didn't
give it to me dumb [ __ ] but I knew it
and pretty soon you don't get hired for
10 20 jobs in a row and you're on a hot
streak now you're actually feeling
pretty good that you called it 20 times
in a row you're not getting the job and
then guess what happens
you go to the 21st interview and you
give it your best and you walk away and
they go Todd where are you going
I'm out of here because I know you're
not going to hire me and they go no
we actually want to offer you a job and
here's why that's an awesome day because
what's sort of kind of caused it
frustrate first off they break my streak
of 20 no's in a row so I'm a little
frustrated that my streak went away
because I'm like God damn it they broke
my streak but by breaking my streak I
got the job I got the job it's a good
day here's what most people do Tim and
my family members do the same thing and
I can't help them it's personality they
actually think they're going to get
every job they go and apply for and when
we they don't they get crushed it
literally crushes their soul for two or
three days
and they're just
they're a shell of a person why because
they put the bar High the bar was that
we were going to get the job no put the
bar where it says I'm not getting the
job and you will never be disappointed
assume today is not going to be perfect
and assume human beings are flawed and
you will have a pretty damn good life
because guess what happens some days
nobody Cuts you off nobody cuts in line
and nobody writes you a bad email and
it's a pretty good day it's a pretty
good day because
sort of discomfort didn't come not that
you won the lottery not that you didn't
that your team won the championship you
just didn't have a lot of aggravation
you didn't get sued today cool it's a
good day I don't know it I I psyched
myself out I psych myself out
for little success so when any of it
comes it's cool we talked about it with
selling the toys at sixty thousand
there's either way to get to sixty
thousand sales and it be a negative or
it can be a positive it depends on how
you psych yourself out I am a horrible
golfer horrible golfer I don't do it
much
also I've had people say Todd you're the
worst golfer who doesn't care here's why
I don't care because I don't Golf and so
I don't golf I don't assume I'm Gonna
Get Better by not golfing every three
years any more than my Mandarin and my
Spanish is going to get better by me not
practicing either one of those languages
either you don't get better by not doing
it so when I go golf the odd time I'm in
Phoenix I'm horrible but every now and
then I get lucky and all of a sudden I
get a par five I get a six I am dancing
naked when I get a six on a on a par
five and but but it's interesting with
another guy who must have had a
different expectation his bar was
different than mine he hits it he hits
it he gets a sixth and he is so mad he
actually breaks his club that costs more
than my entire rental
and he breaks his club and I'm sitting
there going wow he got a six I got a six
it's the same number I'm dancing naked
and he's cursing up a storm he must have
had a different expectation than me so
that's it I just keep my expectations
low It Gets You Through there